[Music]
along with the hottest movie of the year
heading to your living room we've got a
Kenneth Brana horror flick the return of
your favorite fictional Morning Show and
one movie based on an historical figure
that's definitely not true and one based
on a famous person that is true it's all
coming up on this week's what to watch
hey Barbie
can I come to your house tonight
I don't have anything they planned just
a giant blowout party with all the
Barbies and planned choreography in a
bespoke song you should stop by so cool
after absolutely dominating theaters for
a month or so it's time for Barbie to
pack up her little plastic suitcase and
head to your house through video on
demand of course now look if you haven't
seen Barbie yet and you're one of these
film purists who think anything with no
film Grant should even be in the
conversation then we have some news for
you because Barbie is looking to be a
major Awards Contender at the next
Oscars that's right we may not only see
it up for best picture and Best Director
but also best original screenplay having
been one of the biggest comedies ever
and Ryan Gosling for best supporting
actor as Ken is that more than enough
for you if not there's obviously the 1.4
billion other reasons as in the amount
of money Barbie has made at the
worldwide box office that makes it the
highest grossing Warner Brothers film
ever the highest grossing film of the
year and the highest grossing film
directed by a woman Barbie you're are 10
in our books
but I can talk to the Dead
I give all I have to you my daughter's
voice if someone wants to be heard
you are here
listening
hitting feeders this week is the mystery
thriller a haunting in Venice this
Halloween themed flick was directed and
co-produced by Kenneth Branagh and
serves as a sequel to last year's death
on the Nile with Brana reprising his
role as Belgian detective Hercule Poirot
for a third time and that's the first
reason to check this one out the second
is that along with Brana the ensemble
cast includes folks like Tina Fey Jamie
Dornan and the always awesome Michelle
yo they're all part of this story that
takes place in post-world War II Venice
where someone is murdered during a
seance the third reason to consider a
haunting in Venice is that it's based on
the 1969 Agatha Christie novel Halloween
party all three entries in brana's
current Trilogy are based on Agatha
Christie novels and all are currently
fresh on the Tomato Meter if it ain't
broke you know I'm all over this network
I need to have a say in the future of
this place what you are asking is
unprecedented
I am unprecedented checking in once
again with weather and the traffic
updates is the third season of Apple
TV's the morning show it's been a couple
of years since we last Saw new episodes
from the series so let me remind you
that both seasons one and two are fresh
on the Tomato Meter with an average
audience score of 80 percent that's good
and that's the first reason to set your
station for this morning show the second
is a reminder of this star-studded cast
featuring Jennifer Aniston's first
mainstream TV role since friends and
Steve Carell's first since the office
and a couple of TV Legends back on TV
makes for a great reason to keep up with
this show plus with a new season comes
more big time Talent joining the cast in
this case names like Jon Hamm and
tignataro will be getting it on the fun
and that fun will include things like a
Cyber attack and money problems at the
station plus plenty more drama to go
around
arriving on Netflix is the black comedy
horror flick El Conde the first reason
to put this one on your queue for this
weekend is the interesting and funny
premise a satire that shows Chilean
dictator Augusto Pinochet as a 250 year
old vampire now seeking death yeah you
heard that right and while the film star
Jaime vadel and director Pablo Lorraine
may not sound familiar to you they are
absolute Legends in the film World
Lorraine has been nominated for multiple
Oscars for his films such as Jackie and
most recently Spencer which is pretty
cool and just might make you a little
more well-rounded as a movie fan and
with about 50 reviews in and Counting El
Conde is certified fresh at 84 on the
Tomato Meter with a critics consensus
that calls it a Darkly Delirious satire
rooted in real life horror you had me at
Darkly delirious
[Music]
I've been doing real fights since a
couple of years ago yeah
they don't see nothing else and hitting
theaters for a limited time before
heading to Prime is the biopic Cassandra
this film follows the rise to stardom of
Saul armendariz a gay amateur wrestler
from El Paso who would become the
Liberace of Lucha Libre challenging a
macho world with his own take on the
sport and given the entertainment and
education value of a good biopic that's
the first reason to see this one the
second is that this marks the narrative
directorial debut of Roger Ross Williams
who had previously told Cassandra's
story in a 2016 documentary short called
The Man Without a mask in other words
the guy knows how to tell this story and
along with the fact that music sensation
Bad Bunny plays a supporting role in
this one it's worth noting that critics
are loving Cassandra which is sitting at
95 percent on the Tomato Meter with
plenty of critical praise for the film
star Garcia Bernal
well there you have it five picks to
match whatever energy level you have at
the time be sure to let us and your
fellow viewers know in the comments what
you did check out whether it was on this
list or not remember to check out
rottentomanos.com for the latest updates
on scores and reviews for everything
mentioned as well as the movie and TV
World At Large that's all for today
fresh family until next week stay fresh